okay
thank you
foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilet but shakes
[Music]
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elephants and bathrooms
elements of bathrooms what on Earth is
going on with Trump and toilets Obama
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation the big massive dumps
10 times
[Music]
the United States thank you very much
elements of bathrooms
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
blah blah
la la la la la la la la la la
[Music]
la la la
la la la la
[Music]
la la la
[Music]
mangoes my bags of mangoes
I love mangoes too
I'll find his regime
pack of mangoes now costs
[Music]
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified from the
mango
ES
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well thank you for having me into your
home today it is another Donald Trump
rally and I know I'm already getting
some people criticizing me because the
title says it is completely unhinged and
someone a couple people in the chat were
saying how do you know it's unhinged
it's not exactly journalism to say that
before it starts well number one I'm not
a journalist I've never pretended to be
I'm a commentator and I'll do whatever
the hell I want on my YouTube channel
and twitch but Trump's literally using
the same script for the last year we
know the speech he comes out and he says
it's dangerous because of the Democrats
and Biden's demented and trans people
are bad and ding ding I did the
weightlifting and then they played the
music and he talks about how horrible
things are and then he says make America
great again safe again you know all this
different stuff then he dances and then
he leaves okay guys that's it that's the
speech so we know we know that that's
how it's going to be
wearing my glasses again today by
popular demand yesterday I wore my
glasses it went really well there is
some kind of a line dance of sorts
seemingly happening right now at the
rally uh I don't know exactly what it is
I can assure you it is not Hava Nagila
that is definitely for sure let's take a
little bit of a listen here oh I also
shaved yes people noticing I shaved a
beautiful beautiful shave uh let's
listen to what pillow is saying and then
we're going to get to some other things
credential it's the house all of that
um and they're voting basically for the
Brazilian Trump they have bolsonaro he's
a good friend of mine his son Edwardo
tomorrow so you probably you're well
aware of all of this I'm really cheering
for did he refer to Eduardo as Ferraro
okay from there they live in
it's going to win and they've got the
correct look it's gonna be rigged rigged
rig machines
um
action lawsuit against all machines
that's the uniparty globalist Deep State
everybody and I've talked to Eduardo to
barcenario the uh they actually wanted
bar zanara are you are you guys familiar
with the Brazilian president barzanara
sounds more like a Godfather character
than a Brazilian guy beans and with the
media and everything there those polls
that
behind that's because they're gonna
steal it with the computers right and
then everyone will go oh you know it was
over 54 countries have now been taken by
the machines we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines barzanara
is going to have it stolen by the
machines thousands but I will give you
hope State our countries like the
Netherlands they got rid of their
machines that we're never getting our
country taken the Netherlands got rid of
them in five months France Italy Germany
all these countries and a guy just asked
me over there well Mike it takes forever
to do a a can count no France did it in
two hours and they have 70 million
people we have double that I get two
more people to watch and count the
ballots and we we ought to get there
um yeah France has 70 million people but
how many votes but what do you do and
also they don't have states where every
state has different rules I mean is it
this guy is very very sick
70 which is I think he's got about 200
million people that have come to this
Common Sense bucket however they see the
corruption yeah yeah right they can sit
there and say oh it's a divided country
it's 50 50. no it's not just like here
in Michigan this is what 70 of the
country supports Trump there's a very
very interesting idea somehow like what
22 percent of the country actually voted
for Trump or something like that
um okay
this speech is in Warren Michigan it
looks to me like there's about
[Music]
um
there's probably two what do you think I
think two million people there two and a
half something like that
maybe three million people at this
speech it's a really big crowd that I
can tell you for sure
um
and I'm sure very 2.2 million at least
yeah good point Green Man five million
now 5 million sounds like too much maybe
there's five million including the
people waiting outside who weren't
allowed in that's another big one that
Trump loves to mention all right super
chats are dumping in and I want to get
to some of them sorry if we've already
discussed have you kept up with the
chess cheating drama yes I have
addressed the chess cheating drama on
the world famous bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad yeah let's go pillow
guy
David did you hear the Department of
Education change rules on student loan
forgiveness and made legal concerns not
yet I will research
hey David did you hear the Department of
Education change their rules on student
loan forgiveness amid legal concerns no
someone else already asked that oh it
was you you asked it twice beautiful
well I read it twice which is an
important thing we have a couple
interesting things I wanted to show you
do you guys want to see a real exorcism
and I'm gonna admit to you I don't know
what it means that it's real versus fake
the concept of a real exorcism it's sort
of like saying real Homeopathy it's by
definition not
real
anyway what do you you want to see one I
guess is the question
all right let's check it out here is a
um
actually this I don't know if this
actually is an exorcism this might just
be a Christian filled by the Holy Ghost
check this out uh oh we're muted hold on
yep and he was just now he's a
podiatrist after what happened in this
video he's now a podiatrist
uh so he can do ingrown toenails or if
you need Orthotics or anything like that
that this is basically the training
isn't that something
let's look at it just once more
[Music]
you know I can't tell whether he's
taking a demon out or putting a demon in
to be totally Frank it's it's not clear
to me
you know what's funny is whether you run
the video forwards or backwards it's not
clear whether this guy has been cured of
demonic possession or has been infected
with demonic possession during this
event I guess
um
it's both okay yeah he both has been
cured and infected with the demonic
possession yeah so anyway that's I guess
an exorcism to people who find that
interesting apparently he's now cured of
what we don't know but he's not exactly
he's now been cured very very well said
I want to say thank you to Jason
sickmeyer Jason just signed up at
joinpakman.com and his new member number
one today also it is an explosive
situation over on Twitch our great
friend s Perez just gifted 20
subscriptions on Twitch I also want to
say thanks to Beth Graham physicist
Badness mechanically reclaimed meet
Bernie on a boat Ryan Captain Smiles
Uncle Chuckles micro Kimmy all getting
memberships at twitch putting us at 30.
the goal between now and the election is
for the first time ever to make it to 3
000 active twitch subscribers at once
we've never been there
we're at 1210 right now the number above
my head is not yet updated and that
would be an incredible incredible thing
um let's see what else we have going on
here oh this was brought to my attention
some of you may find it interesting if
you look up David packman on Urban
Dictionary if I've talked about this
before it's been years and I completely
forgot about it
oh hold on people are saying adjust the
stream audio okay let me turn that down
uh that's this one okay I think I just
dealt with that
uh let me see if I can do anything else
about it now okay so David packman is
defined in Urban Dictionary as a
self-righteous liberal who thinks his
mind is the greatest thing in the
universe obviously that's not true I
think it's the greatest thing in the
world
but the universe would be a little
pompous even for me and then it has an
incorrect quote where it says all
Republicans are racist and anti-science
I that I am misquoted that is absolutely
not uh
quote that is accurate so anyway that's
um that's the definition on Urban
Dictionary
of David packman which is which is
pretty freaky if you ask me
uh and then oh I played this last night
but I want to do this again just to give
people an opportunity
there is a new audio track that someone
made for the show
and I am inviting people to make a music
video for this and if you submit one
there's a really good chance that it'll
become part of the introductory
um elements of the show and I am going
to play that for you now this is by
casual divide and it's called David
packman C Shanty now a couple people
yesterday said the tempo's a little low
just add 10 to the tempo that's easy to
fix okay so you can find the file casual
divide on Soundcloud here we go I'm
looking for a place to watch some news
where people don't yell while wearing
suits I know the guy who fits that bill
of aggressive with political will yeah
[Music]
if you like to watch some interviews
from a wide array of different views I
know of a guy who gets it done he's
turning learning into fun but true
[Music]
foreign.com okay anyway you guys get it
I think so that's the um that's the deal
with that you can find that casual
divide on Urban Dictionary and uh make a
video for it submit the video and it'll
be a beautiful beautiful thing
um okay let's look at a couple a couple
of the things taking place at the uh
Trump rally okay we have a beautiful a
series of events here uh taking place
you've got Mike pillow at the rally
Let's uh scroll through and find a
couple oh by the way this is really
weird Doug mastriano who's disgusting
and ignorant which is a pretty dangerous
combination he's running for governor of
Pennsylvania
he says he will ban pole dancing in
schools if he's elected the governor as
well as porn those he will completely
ban them he will he will ban them in
schools okay check this out
actualization our kids pole dancing and
all this other crap that's going on will
be forbidden in our schools
[Applause]
might as well ban the virus
on day one all the graphic
pornographic books that are in
elementary schools will be poor necrophy
he almost said we'll be pulled out
they're going to pull out of all the
books geez
on day one and
gray series out the window
I would love for him to tell us what
that is
um what does he think is happening in
public schools
it's really weird
um so anyway that's what Doug mastriano
is running on meanwhile Josh Shapiro is
running on reality
um Marjorie Taylor green is going with
the Democrats are assassinating people
stuff
I'm not going to mince words with you
all Democrats want Republic instead and
they've already started the killings an
18 year old boy was run down by a
Democrat driver who confessed to I don't
know about that I'm gonna have to look
into that story it's not ringing a bell
I must tell you
um other things happening at the Trump
rally
uh here is the start of Tudor Dixon's
speech
come on
are you excited to see President Donald
J Trump
[Applause]
would you be excited to see Gretchen
Whitmer
that's what I hear I hear she's not
doing any public events because she's
afraid of what was that sound again
[Applause]
yeah I guess I guess
I guess
lock up people who not only haven't been
convicted of anything
they haven't even been charged it's the
party of Law and Order here is Marjorie
Trader green
and my grandfather
Great Lakes
he was a member of the Union there just
like so many others and that did she say
the yin yang he was a member of the yin
yang what did she say
he was a member of the Union there oh
the union oh my God I could I barely
have any idea what she's saying it's
like so many others in that day so I
might be a Southern Belle and a Georgia
Peach but Michigan runs in my it looks
more like a rotten apple to me
um here is Marjorie Taylor green heading
into the rally
this woman tells Marjorie that she's her
voice
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so the crowd pretty visibly
excited more chance to lock people up
who have not been uh even charged with
anything she has all the tools there's
no excuse
me apparently currently my opponent
laughs
lock everybody up I mean just if you
don't like them just put them in prison
that seems to be uh that seems to be the
idea that they're going for here
let's see what else happened
um here's another guy trying to give a
speech but the lock them lock them up
chance overwhelm disastrous Democratic
policies
and in fact Dan kildee
Dan Kilby is so
all of that but he's so grossly
objectionable great electric public
speaker as you can see here
um okay so we did the Marjorie Taylor
green stuff already
what else oh he'll see what this is
about but the but the person that must
be held account able for January 6th
yeah
that's that's really disturbing stuff
um
she mentioned Pete Buddha judge it was
probably a homophobic comment right like
I don't even know what she said but it
if she if she's talking about mayor Pete
I assume it's homophobic more American
than the Roar of a V8 engine under the
hood of a Ford Mustang or Chevy Camaro
an incredible feel of all that
horsepower
but Democrats like Pete bootage want to
emasculate the way
there it is of course the gay Secretary
of Transportation wants to emasculate
you yeah what what a surprise what a
surprise we drive
and force all of you to rely on electric
vehicles after they shut down your great
Michigan auto vehicles uh I would rather
be relying on an electric vehicle than
uh some V8 Chevy truck that's just
dumping exhaust all over the place these
people are quite quite sick
um something about AOC who cares she
doesn't look like AOC we know that
um here's the opening prayer I know many
of you are deeply spiritual and when you
go uh when you seek spiritual guidance
you think I want prayer from the guy
opening the Trump rally
Among Us servants who are mindful of
this namely those who will stand as
president Trump has stood
let them seek to preserve religious
liberty Desiring to maintain the freedom
to live peaceful and quiet lives
according to the doctrines of Faith
right use them to impede all attempts to
burden Godly consciences with unjust
laws employ them as ramparts against
anyone who would confuse the objective
truths of your natural law demonstrated
quite clearly in human sexuality restore
Among Us the authority of parents and
the admiration of family reminding all
in our nation of this holy estate's role
as the most powerful agent for a free
society's stability all right anyway
here's a Super Chat which I love from
Denver McCarthy please join me in a
moment of prayer that there will be
another hilarious audio disaster during
the rally yeah now that's something I
would actually consider praying for
remember when this happened at Trump's
last rally this is not edited in any way
and watch your ears if you're wearing
headphones
further scream that his days
[Music]
all right anyway let's hope that that
actually happens
um during today's speech that would be
that would be really great
I'm extremely uh hopeful for that and I
would I would consider prayer I would
consider prayer for that
um okay all right let's
um let's continue though I want to see
what else what else happened
uh they're blaming democrats for
inflation okay that's not surprised I
don't even I'm not even gonna bother
with that that's not a shock
um
I just start talking about illegals
Herschel Walker stuff I don't know that
we can even tolerate more Herschel
Walker stuff
a newly single Marjorie Taylor green yes
let's see what this is here's Christina
Bob one of Trump's lawyers who's also an
anchor for right side broadcasting yeah
Trump loves her name he every time he
talks to me he says tutor everybody's
gotta love that name right everybody
loves that name and I said they do but
you're right name recognition is
probably the biggest obstacle but again
Trump he likes the name Tudor okay
Jordan says the big three Detroit
automakers are making a huge push to
electric vehicles what is she talking
about yeah right it's not even accurate
what she's saying is it just me or is
Marjorie Taylor Green's smirky little
grin she just does the most disgusting
thing she knows how slimy she is and
loves every minute of it yeah I find
that smirk vile I really do
let me say a couple other thank yous big
thank you to Wesley Taylor Stanley
minarik for gifting two subscriptions
and Desiree Delong for gifting one that
is for putting us at 34 and I also want
to say thanks over on Twitch to Harry
hentinator
Snappy Tam blueberry babe and chatty
Connor for the twitch Prime
subscriptions putting us at 39.
um
do I have any voicemails yeah I I'll do
a voicemail I guess
um it's a little voicemails can always
be you know Touch and Go
but let's see what we've got here
hey James it's Frank from Florida
all as well in South Florida
made it through the hurricane with very
little impacts good I just watched your
show for a bit and saw the exorcism
actually what that is
is they change the normal person to a
Naga person right
and you're awful your numbers there's at
least five million expected at tonight's
rally yes thank you all right thanks
Frank Frank very very closely monitoring
all of these different things let's see
if anything else came in that would be
interesting
so um I started attending this Lutheran
Church and it's a cross speed between uh
Christians and Catholics there was a
posture there and he went and like
volunteered and stuff with the kids then
he had like this other church group
and it was kind of cool because they had
like activities and stuff like that but
it definitely definitely looked like
Seth Rogen and I was wondering the whole
time like maybe he's Jewish or something
okay and we're done we are done okay
thank you very much Whitney very much
appreciate that uh
that input all right I have something
extraordinarily exciting to tell you
guys about
um but also something really really
important as many of you know
we are in the fight for 1.5 million
YouTube subscribers
okay I received the following email from
Sean
and Sean wrote to me and said David sir
I have smoked for 15 years
but if you can get to 1.5
million subscribers tonight
Saturday October 1.
I will quit smoking forever
please David do it for my kids
folks we can do this right now
look at where we are we are 160
subscribers Away on YouTube from 1.5
million and I will do one additional
thing it's not just for the kids it's
not just for the kids I have a coupon
code ready to go
that is 75 off
which will the theme is 1.5
it will make a sixty dollar membership
15 bucks
and it will make a six dollar membership
a dollar fifty right one five I will
unleash this coupon code among you
tonight
if we get to 1.5 million do it for
Michael Jackson's kids
do it for your kids
I don't care who you do it for we are
118
114 subscribers away from 1.5 million
this is on YouTube this is the main
Channel on YouTube we are down to the
last hundred
ladies and gentlemen we thought we might
be able to do it by election day and
then we thought maybe by November 1st
and then we thought maybe by Halloween
and then we thought maybe by the end of
two weeks from now or maybe next week
but we are now 72.
72. there are only two other Progressive
YouTube channels that have reached 1.5
million it's our friends at The Young
Turks they have 70 employees okay
totally different scale and it's our
good friend Brian Tyler Cohen who just
made it last week
and we are 56 No 53 YouTube subscribers
away
from a milestone shared
it is it is a it's a it's a group of
only two
and we've now there's a problem some of
these are machine Subs we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines we are now 37 35 subscribers
away I will unleash a 75 discount code
if we are able to do this I believe in
you
but do you believe in each other is the
question as we are down to the last 19
down to the last 13.
down to the last seven and ladies and
gentlemen we got him ladies and
gentlemen we are now only in a group of
three
Progressive YouTube channels that has
reached 1.5 million YouTube subscribers
it is incredible and we will
men what no why would we do that that's
stupid everybody's welcome here we are
now over 1.5 million
when your grand kids say to you
when we get to some crazy huge number in
the future you know like 1.6 million uh
do you remember where you were
when the David packman show became the
third of three Progressive YouTube
channels to get to 1.5 million you will
be able to say yes it was a minute
before Trump's unhinged Michigan rally
in October of 2022.
it is incredible ladies and gentlemen
thank you the 75 off coupon code on our
website available only until midnight is
another half million with tears in my
eyes I say to you another half million
we have never done anything like it
you get a 75 discount off of memberships
at joinpakman.com our goal is a hundred
and it is absolutely incredible there
are people in the shower right now
watching on their shower devices I don't
even know what that means who who just
saw what we were able to do just moments
before Donald Trump's arrival moments
before Donald Trump's arrival thank you
congratulations I am humbled at your
feet look at these beautiful numbers and
people have shower devices and all of
these different things the coupon code
because we did it is another half
million and I will do my best to thank
everybody who uses that code super chats
or dumping in faster than I can even put
them up let's take a look s Prez with a
hundred fifty dollar Super Chat Mazel
Tov congratulations we have
uh David Moore says congratulations on
1.5 million that's 1.5 million more than
there are accurate statements on Troth
Central absolutely
graveborn just gifted 50. YouTube
subscriptions
uh David sir congrats on 1.5 thank you
Kenneth
Wesley says I've been smoking for 15
years I'll quit if you reach 1.5 well
Wesley you better you better drop the
six Beetle tuba with a congratulations
Kyoko with a congrats
Andrew
congrats on being the first progressive
show with panels to reach 1.5 million
absolutely
uh bing bang was a big big
congratulations Hilario with
congratulations Tila
and uh just a lot of beautiful messages
Dems voting big time coming up no doubt
about it
no doubt about it folks it looks like
the website is absolutely getting
crushed by people desperate to use the
coupon code another half million who
will be the first to use it it is candy
Crow candy Crow signing up and is new
member number 90 it is amazing amazing
what is happening here my friends as we
are just moments away from Donald Trump
speaking I want to say thank you to
Simply Rey and eternal toil for gifting
some subscriptions that's seven thanks
to hey bear and Harry
uh very very much appreciate that
putting us at 99.
and we did it folks we did it it's uh oh
people are saying that there's more even
dumping in
yeah there we go it's continuing
it's absolutely continuing folks the
stream is just getting started s Prez
dumping in another 20 memberships let's
see if we can shoot uh for 200 I am
going to
see who else I can say thanks to Patrick
Wolfe is a new member
hold on is something wrong with the
coupon code no it's not it's working
fine okay people are gifting
subscriptions one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten I can't even
keep up 11 12 13 14.
15 16 yeah I'll I'll do my I'm gonna
count these up later guys but I'm not
I'm not even able people explosively
going after that coupon code okay let's
see other super chats that are coming in
oh and thanks to Chewie for gifting five
Subs over on YouTube
uh let's see congratulations from Norway
from Ingrid Thank You Ingrid Ingrid
staying up very late with us today
a blueberry congratulations sir you
freaking Predator you yeah I have that
on my Alex Jones section I think
where is that that is a freaking
Predator right there yep Alex Jones is
gonna have a meltdown yeah I don't think
Alex Jones is gonna be pleased about 1.5
million that's for damn sure thanks for
everything David says Lynn thank you
let's see if we can get a couple other
voicemails just squeeze them in
hey David it's Tommy in Wisconsin hey
since they're in Michigan do you think
Trump's going to bring up the uh the
proud boys trying to kidnap Governor
Whitmer and you know probably say that
it's fake news what's the over and under
on that yeah he'll bring it up and say
it was FBI entrapment I think is what
he'll probably say Denver McCarthy says
to celebrate I will be making my own lox
bagel from scratch suggestions on the
brine for the pickled red onions uh I
recently saw a good pickled red onion
recipe I I don't have any specific
suggestions but it's basically a vinegar
base and the red on the onions
themselves is what will turn the entire
thing pink so you don't even have to add
coloring
never thought Finley Craig says I never
thought I'd get to watch such a huge
dump live many congratulations David
thank you memberships dumping in in a
historic way in a completely historic
way uh by the way for people trying to
get themselves memberships if you're
clicking that gift button
I don't know if so many people are
trying to do that deliberately I guess
it's the only the only thing I want to
mention
um okay let's see what else we have here
oh thanks to flea girl broken Realms and
Espress for the subscriptions over on
Twitch let's get a couple more um Clips
here I think we've got other stuff
coming in from the rally which is in
Warren Michigan which is certainly an
interesting place no I guess not now
we're just monitoring continuing to
monitor let's see what is happening in
the exhibit hall as you can see a crowd
of millions of people waiting to hear
from Donald Trump
take all those photos real quick yeah
donors and friends and family together
so Brian's five minute interview is
probably going to be three minutes one
question but hey we're grateful for it
yeah of course would you run for office
knowing like what you've seen first hand
what these politicians and candidates
have to go through you know I think it
takes a special per like I think you are
called for you know like I think Tudor
Dixon is called to run at the right time
at the right time for them I don't I
don't think that I am because I wouldn't
shy away from it like I wouldn't be
scared of it I just don't think I'm the
right person for anyone particular
office
um I think it takes a special kind of
person uh I think you also he is an
attorney all right so that's what's
going on on right side now let's see
what's going on on Newsmax a revolution
yes wow yes it's true I know but the
real main cause the main cause of all
the hot air to cause those hurricanes
back in the day were uh the current
members of The View who were still
around uh that is very true Joy Behar uh
certainly dates back to at least 13
stars on the flag I believe uh Benny I
want to ask you about this because
something that has a lot of Americans uh
pretty Disturbed right now is some words
by our vice president uh talking about
relief uh for people affected by the
hurricane uh essentially saying they're
looking at race-based relief for people
uh which I think uh is certainly
something very upsetting this hurricane
doesn't did Kamala Harris say that I
haven't heard that everything you know
Sanibel Island Fort Myers those areas
hit so hard these people are still
picking up the pieces we still don't
know how many people are in homes there
that haven't been rescued uh and and
Kamala Harris uh you know taking a cue
from Rahm Emanuel never let a crisis go
to race go to waste uh making it all
about race never let a crisis go to race
is Trump coming out because people seem
to be reacting to some degree oh
[Applause]
well I think I think they were hoping
all right so scrumps is going to speak
soon just to review once again some of
the most interesting moments from the
last rally where when Trump had an audio
failure that his days
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so we're hoping that that will
happen again at one point Trump said
during his last speech that we have to
keep America gay we have to keep keep
our country gay perfect but it's not I
mean okay
um at another moment Donald Trump said
the following people people starting to
that was a really strange moment and
then lastly here's what Donald Trump had
to say about one of the people he was
supporting there well he's going to
represent you
long and hard yeah it was a really
really strange speech last time I can
only hope that today's speech is half as
disastrous
um okay I'm just gonna mention there's a
lot of people saying hey David I'm
signing up with the with the code and
you're there are so many people signing
up on my website right now because we
have an explosive coupon code that ends
at midnight I can't even say everybody's
names I'm not going to do that to you
all just know that if you were just
joining us today and today only we just
reached 1.5 million subscribers on the
YouTube channel as a result we have
generated a coupon code another half
million another half million and that
code is the greatest and most powerful
membership discount we have ever had
before it's 75 off at joinpakman.com it
is an unbelievable thing and I encourage
everybody to take advantage of that but
I I just I can't even keep up with
people's names because there are so many
people signing up that I'll count them
up once once the speech starts okay
other super chats continuing to come in
um Zachary says speaking of deranged the
most deranged thing this week was
dangerous zero coveted people on Twitter
sending death threats to Public Health
people because they dared eat inside a
restaurant maskless I didn't see it but
it sounds nuts
Henrik from Denmark says looks like the
nordics are going to money bomb David So
any swedes want to money bomb I can
trade you guys beer the Swedish that is
Skull
uh man Henrik I don't know what's going
on I missed that there was there was uh
Norwegian stuff going on
okay Michelle says thank you for
broadcasting this the funny thing is my
area wouldn't be caught dead in Warren
these days right
absolutely
David sir how about subscriptions for
Jesse dollamore in support of his recent
cancer diagnosis yes I did a shout out
to our great friend Jesse dollimore who
recently
um told us that he has been diagnosed
indeed with colon cancer it's horrifying
and uh we want to support Jesse and you
can find out more about it on his
channel but really horrible horrible
news and we continue to send Jesse our
absolute best
do these people realize Trump says the
same lines at every rally it's hilarious
and pointless quite frankly I don't know
what they realize
I don't know what they realize it's it's
unclear that they realize anything at
this point in time
uh thanks to Texas bear claw
um for the twitch Prime subscription
number 146 we have a goal today of 200
and I believe it's plausible that we
could get there a couple other
voicemails to play for you for folks who
like voicemails David sir I actually
need to express some gratitude to you
this morning I would not have known that
there was a trump rally today if you
didn't have it on your uh in your live
notification all right one thing I don't
understand is like where where's the
news on these I mean he's having a trump
rally every weekend and he's under
investigation for all this stuff it's
like you know what if they charged him
with one thing he would be uh under so
much like legal stuff he couldn't have
these Trump values I don't even know
that I agree with that I think even if
Trump was charged he would continue
doing rallies I think and he would talk
about the charges I think it would be
crazy I I don't think it would deter him
whatsoever like at all at all at all
I appreciate your little girl who I've
in my head named Shoshanna Juliet
Parkman
I know
um no soy here what really
have you given in to the haters wait
what what
I cannot believe that no
I mean you should be wearing your
badge of you know soy boy
of Honor proudly
because okay I know it has nothing to do
with really what you know that's why boy
but what if your daughter
had to be drinking soy formula
you know Denmark
and again I know it has nothing to do
really is that even a thing is there
formula is there soy formula for babies
I've never heard of them
right
you are nearly 2 million subscribers
it's not already no we just hit 1.5
and
I know you put up with a lot
I
yeah
sorry boy is your badge of honor
yeah anyway that's the joke okay guys
that's the joke the joke is no soy here
it was right after the Allison Steinberg
thing where she said I was soy infused
it's it's just a joke guys you know
everybody relax not everything has to be
like crazy the most important thing you
know
1.5 million is just the main YouTube
channel if we add in our nearly 100
000 twitch followers and then about 40K
on the second YouTube channel and 10K on
the finance Channel and 100K on
Instagram and like close to 200k on
Facebook we are close to 2 million total
that is absolutely true absolutely true
can't deny that
um okay other messages coming in
no I guess not
I guess not
um so we'll look at a couple hold on
congrats on 1.5 crazy how you and Brian
Tyler Cohen hit 1.5 back to back days no
that's not true Brian tweeted about it
yesterday but he hit it a while ago
here is uh the failed former president
Donald Trump I think we will probably be
over on Newsmax for this let's make sure
that in terms of our quality we are at
the highest quality let's listen
but there ain't no doubt yeah
so Donald Trump will be speaking
momentarily if you were just joining us
it is a momentous day on which the main
YouTube channel hit 1.5 million
subscribers
thanks to that we have launched an
explosive coupon code good only until
midnight or later if I forget to disable
it and that code is another half million
all one word another half million boom
that is it and I will tally them up once
Trump starts speaking as you can see
Trump visibly disoriented here and that
is not uncommon so I'm so glad to see
everybody here
and it's fantastic thanks to sansalev
for the twitch Prime subscription we may
indeed get to 200 and you will see the
numbers tick up once Donald Trump starts
speaking uh super chats will stay live
for the entire speech I'm hoping that it
is not a Fidel Castro like two and a
half hour speech I'm hoping it's nice
and short unfortunately this one is
indoors one of the big things that keeps
Trump's speeches short is when the
temperature isn't good if it's too hot
or too cold Trump will often cut the
speech short this one's indoors so
unfortunately we may be in for a long
one if Donald Trump's Comfort level
is uh
uh is high Trump's also only 20 minutes
late which is another factor that might
make this a very very long one
um so I am hoping that it is not
insanely long but at the same time it
would be interesting if it was a
record-long speech a lot of indicators
suggesting a very long speech Let's
listen here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what an electric crowd
I can't even tell what they're chanting
my my this is a big crowd and I want to
just say hello Michigan we love Michigan
and I'm thrilled to be back in This
Magnificent state with thousands of
proud hard-working American Patriots
thank you very much
bikers for Trump very present today
profound
or immense support to everyone back in
Florida and Georgia the Carolinas who
are struck by this brutal Wrath of
the hurricane not a good hurricane this
was a big one you know a lot of times
they say the Hurricane's coming and
nothing happens this was a bad one this
was a really bad one so we just want to
say hello to everybody in that area and
we want to say we love you very much
and we do
what empathy incredible empathy with you
and our prayers are with you thank you
we'll all stay strong together we'll
pull through it that was a bad bad
couple of days six weeks from now the
people of Michigan are going to vote to
fire your radical left Democrat Governor
correction
oof
and you're going to send a very good
person a very very good woman tutor
Dixon to the governor's mansion tutor
you're going to elect one of the
toughest lawyers I've ever known and
I've known some tough ones and I've
known some good ones he's as good as
they get he's failed to pay more more
lawyers than most people know Matt
deperno as your next Attorney General
are you going to do a job Matt
and a woman that is just a fantastic
talent and a fantastic person Christina
caramel Christina
thank you thank you
what a good Secretary of State
and somebody that I've known for a long
time he did great I think he happened to
win the last election for the Senate I
happen to think he won it by quite a bit
and now he's way how much people won by
is now a matter of opinion Trump thinks
he won by a lot in John James
fight for Congress
John James
thank you thank you John
great guy and together we're going to
end crazy Nancy Pelosi's political
career once and for his face
she is crazy
under Biden Whitmer Pelosi Schumer and
the radical democrat congress natural
gas utility bills are up 52 at least
[Applause]
prayers are up almost 50 percent and
here in Michigan the cost of gasoline is
up 79 it would have been down
since I left office the average Michigan
family is paying over one hundred and
seven dollars more per month for food
think of that 78 dollars more for
housing 275 dollars more for
transportation monthly bases and 164
dollars more
per month for a thing called Energy and
it's going way up because they're
usually using these strategic reserves
that we topped out first time in 51
years
75 million barrels I bought only to be
used so they can keep the price of
gasoline down just a little bit for an
election not supposed to be used for
that supposed to be used for trouble
like wartime and Military trouble not to
keep
price is down by the way they didn't do
too good in keeping the prices down in
it because you have record setting
energy and take a look at your electric
bill by the way that's all part of it
the typical American family is losing
over four thousand two hundred dollars a
year in income because of the inflation
created just in the last year and a half
Trump's a little confused about how
finance and economics Works higher
created by the Democrat Party
the increase in mortgage rates means an
ordinary home buyer has lost nearly
three hundred thousand dollars in
purchasing power murders in Michigan
let's talk about crime murders in
Michigan are up by over 30 percent
carjackings in your state are up by
listen to this one
764 percent
[Applause]
everybody get Matt deperno in there
he'll stop it
get tutor Dixon get Christina
the tutor will take care of it
Matt you don't you know the carjackers
do you I don't think so Matt 700 and
just said it's ridiculous
the choice in this election is simple if
you want the decline and fall of America
then vote for the radical left Democrats
that's what's happening we have a nation
as they say in decline if you want to
stop the destruction of our country and
save the American dream you must vote
Republican you have to
I don't think you have a choice I don't
even think that'll change
as bad as things are today if the
radical Democrats keep their grip on the
house and the Senate the situation will
only get worse probably not no flood the
country with tens of millions more
illegal aliens by the way nobody's ever
seen anything like what's happening
right now with our border we had to
border the strongest ever in the history
of our country and now we have maybe the
worst Border in the world because I
don't believe third world countries
evidence I found is that carjackings in
Michigan are up 40 percent not 764 I am
through Mass amnesty and give illegal
aliens welfare free health care and the
right to vote they want to give them
more than we give our
they want to give them more than we give
our great warriors our military they
want to do better for them than they do
for our military we're not going to let
it happen they will abolish the
filibuster obliterate election Integrity
which they've already done to be totally
honest with you gut our military
bankrupt the treasury trash the currency
and incinerate trillions of dollars in
middle class wealth and it's happening
to you all the time down over 7 800
middle-income families in terms of worth
if we get two more years of democrat
rule your finances your family your
community in your country might never
recover you may never recover this is so
bad between what's happened to our
military what's happened to our border
what's happening we're never going to
recover what happened to this country
you may not recover but we will save the
day okay we will save today
but frankly your vote is the only thing
that can stop and so on November 8th
Michigan Patriots have to shatter every
record because they cheat like hell
these people they cheat like him
remember they said oh no there was no
corruption in Detroit none whatsoever
foreign
no votes no votes what happened to all
those votes it's a shame my shame what
happened to who would have thought our
elections are so rigged and crooked who
would have thought our borders are open
they want no voter ID you know why they
don't want voter ID they fight voter ID
because they want to cheat
you have to defy every prediction and
you have to swamp Gretchen Whitmer the
radical Democrats with a colossal red
Republican wave
oh boy
before our very eyes the radical left
Democrats are waging a full-scale
assault on the most sacred so far
Trump's staying mostly on script which
might mean that he actually wants to
wrap this up relatively quickly would be
interesting to see let's see if he goes
off onto his rants indoctrinate your
children criminalize dissent and even
put their political opponents in prison
I think they'd like to see me in prison
can you imagine I think they'd like I
would like to see Trump in prison if
there's evidence with which to charge
him and then he's convicted is that fair
is that Law and Order completely corrupt
jailing political opponents just like
the Soviet Union now Russia
the Soviet Union now Russia think of it
we're being compared to that by maybe
I'm just supposed to say lock them up
like they do the criminal justice system
I think it's the criminal Injustice
system if the Communists win and now
we're talking Communists we don't say
socialist anymore right because we've
already skipped over socially Trump
doesn't know the difference so who cares
right never had we and I don't believe I
don't believe we'll ever have a fair
election again
I don't believe it never just days ago
the FBI sent dozens and dozens of agents
to raid and arrest a Catholic pro-life
activist and father of seven in
Pennsylvania and bogus pretext in an
outrageous Act of religious persecution
and political repression sisters you
hear that right you know all about that
don't you look at these beautiful
incredible sisters they were so tough
they were so tough
stand up sisters so beautiful
they were so tough but you know what
they could teach
and they didn't stand for any nonsense
look how nice they looked but they were
they were strong we need you very badly
and very unfair what's happening to
religious liberty you know that you know
that better than anybody thank you very
much thank you
likewise the Biden Administration has
locked up dozens and dozens of political
prisoners in horrific conditions
horrible horrible conditions in
Washington so filthy so dirty that
people don't even want to go there to
look
they don't want to look they get sick
and by the way somebody that did they go
there is Marjorie Taylor Greene
who's now single
and she didn't like what she saw what
she saw she said she told me I've never
seen anything like it in my life what
they're doing to these people and even
solitary confinement for protesting and
that's what they did they protested on
January 6. you know what that was isn't
it terrible how they're treating the
insurrectionists protesting
persecuting people who just happened to
be there many of them didn't even go in
I am their number one Target but I am
proud to be fighting for you and I'm
going to be fighting for you
for a long time
this is crazy
truly crazy
foreign
guys let me know in the chat is he going
to do the transgender rant where he says
teachers should not be allowed to teach
transgender I never thought I'd have to
say this frankly but let's talk about
the persecution of Donald Trump and the
Republican party let's talk about it oh
no on January 6
2021 I made a speech entitled peacefully
and patriotically
three days before realizing there were
going to be perhaps one million people
people never talk about how many people
are there it's one of the largest crowds
I've ever spoken before nobody ever
talks about it
pictures of the crowds have disappeared
unless they give you pictures from five
o'clock in the morning yep you can't
find them one million people at the
potentially historic speech which it
turned out to be a historic speech it
was potentially recommended and
authorized to numerous people including
the Secretary of Defense and others
ten thousand to twenty thousand troops
to ensure peace safety and protection
there is no evidence Trump made that
request no evidence Pelosi and the mayor
of Washington DC
that's a lie they said they didn't like
the look of it
but that means there was no Insurrection
because somebody creating an
Insurrection doesn't recommend from 10
to 20 000 troops to keep everybody safe
but you won't hear about that from the
fake news media right back there there's
a lot of them
okay you won't hear about it many lies
here I keep saying we authorize from 10
to 20 000 and it's in the Obama from
previous the Obama inspector General's
report and they turned it down and they
don't want to talk about the unselect
committee
doesn't want to talk about it
it's a complete scam the unselect
committee is a complete and total scam
The Witch Hunt is run by two rhinos who
have been thrown out of the Republican
Party Liz Cheney and crying Adam
oh boy in fact Liz Cheney lost her
election
in the great state of Wyoming we love
Wyoming
we love Wyoming but she lost her
election by 40 points a record loss for
a sitting member of Congress in other
words no congressperson has ever lost by
that
and you know who was second a guy named
rice from South Carolina 26 points but
she obliterated you know what he was he
was an impeacher and she was an
impeacher and kinsinger was an impeacher
and I guess this is super dangerous
the only one
the only one that made it but we'll get
them next time
he had seven only trumpers running
against him so he had seven people only
Trump we call him only trumpers they
don't accept anybody else but we had
seven only dropped against one guy he
got like 17 percent
but we say we'll get him next time
but we have we have no representation on
the committee no right to have lawyers
present no opportunity to cross-examine
Witnesses and we have no due process
whatsoever it's a runaway freight train
that frankly the people of our country
aren't even watching the ratings are
down the tubes nobody cares at this
point many witnesses are lying writing
books and embarrassing Congress and
demeaning our country people who were in
or left the administration said great
things that I want to write a great book
about the president oh we love our
president he's so great we love our
president but we're told by the biased
horrible Publishers throughout the
country there aren't too many of them
left actually that if you don't say
something bad about President Trump we
will never publish your book but we'll
pay you a lot of money if you're willing
to say something bad and some of them
gave into the dark side and wrote lies
and fabricated stories all sorts of
stories I had a story the other day that
I wanted to fire my daughter Ivanka that
didn't happen
no but how do you how do you call your
daughter and explain this right you know
they read this this disgusting talk that
was a writer from the fake New York
Times the failing New York Times a lot
of unfunded liability yeah
[Applause]
if Ivanka weren't my daughter perhaps
I'd be dating her daughter thinks thinks
that she's my biographer even though she
knows me a lot less than some of the
people standing right on that platform
right back there
some of whom are okay like about 10
percent
[Applause]
I think about it I would like to thank
a great woman named Ginny Thomas do you
know Jenny Jones oh no
she's a great woman oh no the wife of a
great man Justice Clarence Thomas for
her courage and strength and saying
according to the
standard and routine leaks from the
committee you know everything leaks out
of those committees they're like a
leaking sieve
they're just like a leaking sieve but
she said that she still believes the
2020 election was stolen she didn't say
oh well I'd like not to get involved of
course it was a wonderful election it
was a rigged and stolen election
she didn't wait
and sit around and say well let me give
you maybe a different answer that I've
been saying for the last two years now
now she didn't Wilt Under Pressure like
so many others that are weak people and
stupid people because once they Wilt
they end up being a witness for a long
time
she said what she thought she said what
she believed in too many Republicans are
weak and they're afraid and they better
get strong fast so you're not going to
have a Republican party and you're not
going to have a country is that a
promise
stand up Mike
uh-oh is it pillow
it is a patriot
Mike is a baby there he is
he's the greatest buyer of commercials
in the history of our country this guy
he's got more commercials than anybody
if he's struck oil the oil companies
couldn't afford to put on the
commercials on Youtube will you explain
this to me please someday you're going
to sit down and explain he's the single
greatest commercial buyer but I have
heard you're doing great I have heard
that Patriots are buying those pillows
and they're very good
and everything else great pillows
slippers too this guy's fighting this
fight
and the FBI raided Mike can you believe
it they rated Mike I took his phone
and Mike looked at him like they're
crazy
never happened like this anyway thank
you Mike I appreciate it very much
everybody here appreciates it thank you
bud thank you sir
it's so funny because it's like what
they appreciate what what is he doing
he's not doing anything me including the
racist AG attorney general in New York
whose state is falling apart from
murders rapes robberies drug deals and
every other form of record-breaking
crime
the homeless are sadly but dangerously
roaming all over the streets of New York
City and the city is filthy dirty notice
always the dehumanizing language roaming
have been released the only campaign you
know what her campaign was I didn't know
her she didn't know me I will get Donald
Trump
and she beat a big field of candidates
with a small vote and then you know she
ran for Governors she got like two
percent or something
and then she went right back I said well
does this mean she's leaving the state
from the attorney general because she's
terrible she's terrible on crime unless
it's Donald Trump we can get in some
form but then they shoot me and even
though there was no victim you know
there's no victim
she was trying to protect Banks but the
banks got paid they never even defaulted
they were the fact is I made a lot of
money we have a lot of cash we ever
agree is that going to be the next thing
okay fine I did commit crimes but they
were victimless crimes Vantage of no the
bank said the best lawyers in the
country believe me I know that they're
very smart we don't need her protecting
Banks we need her protecting the people
of New York from being murdered
but I'll play this little video I'll
take a second it's sort of interesting
because you see how they want to
campaign nowadays go ahead please it's
sort of interesting I'm announcing that
today
we are filing a lawsuit against Donald
Trump this lawsuit Carly is due from the
start because the attorney general that
is bringing it she bragged about doing
so we're going to be a real pain in the
ass before she launched anything
resembling an official investigation
it's a frivolous lawsuit there may be
some problems in the lawsuit Leticia
James has politicized this investigation
she campaigned on vote for me and I'll
nail Donald Trump she has fundraised on
it it's hard for me not to conclude it's
a political hit job and this is a woman
Trump hates William Barr now but when
it's convenient he'll include bar in the
video clips the Trump's argument here is
not absurd it's not ridiculous the Crux
of their argument is we have been
politically targeted by this attorney
general Leticia James and you know what
they're right and that's not a matter of
opinion or speculation that's a matter
of fact prosecutors should know when
they take the job they need to be more
careful about talking about politics
even the New York Times pointed out how
weak her allegations are Leticia James
has a real big problem proving fraud
again okay real quick will people cheer
or Boo at the end of this clip
[Applause]
for me vote for me then she gets so
let's see what has Trump done wrong done
nothing wrong that's why it's gone on
for years and years no victim is no
victim except Trump
and let me tell you the judge we have in
the case is even worse than her we got a
judge who's a radical left lunatic
he's treated us so horribly and unfairly
there's never been anything it happened
to me there's never been but you know
what we will persevere we're going to do
very well
but they've treated us very unfairly in
New York and I think it all comes down
from Washington they're telling these
locals to go after they failed they're
telling these locals to go down and get
trump it shouldn't be allowed to happen
in this country this should not be
allowed to happen in the Manhattan DA's
office a number of prosecutors actually
quit I love these people whoever they
may be they quit because they thought I
was being treated unfairly can you nope
that's not why they quit they quit
because they realized they were doing
all this investigative work and there
was not actually any willingness to
charge Trump that's why they quit that's
a straight up lie that Trump is telling
name Cyrus Vance who's by the way whose
father gave away the Panama Canal for
one dollar in perhaps the worst business
deal in history might be the worst deal
ever made after we lost 25 000 people to
malaria the mosquitoes and billions and
billions of dollars to build it many
many years ago and by the way today it's
one of the most successful Enterprises
anywhere in the world those ships are
coming across from China and from every
place you can imagine and they're paying
Panama a fortune money that should be
going to us
and what could only happen to Donald
Trump China there was actually a Hillary
Clinton lawyer with a Hillary Clinton
Law Firm
there it is lock her up the party of Law
and Order calling for someone who hasn't
even been charged to be put in prison
[Applause]
all these great politicians it's never
going to happen to you people maybe a
little bit maybe you'll have one
investigation or two but you won't have
hundreds you won't have hundred you know
if I fly over a Democrat State I get a
subpoena
I tell my Pilots please just fly
now these people are sick but this was a
Hillary Clinton lawyer sick people think
of this her lawyer
her Law Firm who moved into the
Manhattan District Attorney's office and
worked for the Manhattan district
attorney brought his staff along to try
and have me prosecuted how would you
like that so her lawyer actually moved
into the prosecutor's office
the lawyer from Paul Weiss Rifkin
Wharton and Garrison was working for the
Manhattan D.A is that legal they may
have a major liability and this was so
deeply unethical and wrong and it was I
think it was illegal but what do I know
you don't know anything for over a year
to find any way to get that's fair at
least he's saying what do I know he
knows nothing how clean we are
I have a friend who's very smart very
big business person doesn't exist he
said you have to be the most honest
person in the world if I've
had investigations for years and years
it's true
but I believe the
current D.A threw him out I think they
threw about they saw how unfair it was
when the current D.A was elected he saw
how unfair it was but the fact is he and
others really you look at this guy this
lawyer he failed because we've done
nothing wrong and he wanted he worked so
hard it's so unethical think of it
Hillary's Clinton's lawyer and Law Firm
they moved into the Manhattan Hillary
Clinton to get me and it took us a while
we said who is this Maniac turned out to
be Hillary Clinton's lawyer so I don't
think any of you will have a problem
like that one
but the true victims are the people
dying on the streets of New York which
New York's racist attorney general does
absolutely nothing about
she only wants to get Trump
so just think of it they're coming after
me fast and furious not because I did
anything wrong because I didn't I think
they're taking their orders from
Washington but only because they're
trying to hurt me as a candidate and the
millions and millions of people we had
75 million people I think it was much
higher than that I think it was much
higher
400 million people voted Trump for
people the greatest number of people in
the history of our country that ever
voted for a sitting president by a lot
by millions and millions not close by a
lot
but thereafter the America First policy
and make America great again they don't
like that they don't like those words
but look at what we've been through
together Russia Russia Russia Ukraine
Ukraine Ukraine
which would have never happened if I was
president
never impeachment hoax number one
impeachment hoax number two the Mueller
report that came to a conclusion of no
collusion it did not in fact that's
pretty good came to a conclusion of no
collusion you think Biden could say that
I don't think so
that's a pretty good that was it that's
a tough one
but think of that that was there
conclusion
all of this money spent they spent 48
million dollars 18.
mad crazy Democrat radical left maniacs
FBI agents all over the place and after
two years they said
there's no collusion with Russia but I
could have told them on day one and by
the way they knew on day one two they
knew on day one they knew it then we
caught them foreign
spying on my campaign and getting caught
we caught them spying in my camera
untrue as well what do you think would
have
one of hers let's take Obama not Biden
let's
say we got caught spying on his campaign
I do believe they would reinstitute the
death penalty very quickly
as we should do by the way for all drug
dealers okay
you want to see crime drop in this
country you'll see it drop 80 percent or
more
we have our Blue Ribbon committees
however
now we have to do that
but they lied to the fisa court they
lied to Congress they illegally broke in
in my opinion illegally broke in to my
home in Florida in violation of the
fourth amendment can you imagine that
there was nothing unconstitutional about
the search warrant
armed FBI agents also violating the FBI
agents are always armed
and so much more they violated very
simple very reads very simply the
presidential records act and you have to
see bush had a warehouse Bush senior had
a warehouse crooked Hillary Clinton
deleted 33
000 emails many of which were classified
acid washed them
Hillary Clinton Bill Clinton lost a lot
of stuff
Obama didn't they say 33 million pages
of stuff God where is it what happened
and yet with all of the
persecution and prosecution that we've
gone through we I say we all of us
together we are leading everyone in the
polls by a lot
more than ever back in five
it's pretty amazing
you know you see all this stuff and it's
all fake stuff they're fake people but
you see all of this stuff happening and
I say to
a lot of different people that work for
us we have great people I say do you
think that affects us in the polls yes
sir I think you've got up 10 ports we
have we've got up a lot
but we're leading against all
Republicans by more than 50 points every
one of them you know you hear about
different Republicans
and we're beating Biden
by five points or more
and we're beating Kamala Harris the
North Korea sympathizer she's a
sympathizer we're beating her by 10
points now she likes North Korea I think
that was one of the worst mistakes of
all can you imagine they're Standing On
The Border North Korea is over there
shooting off missiles as she's speaking
they shot out two missiles and I got
along very good with Kim Jong-un that's
another one we got along great with Kim
Jong-un we didn't have a problem but he
doesn't like these people too much but
think of it they're shooting off
missiles and she's saying about North
Korea's our Ally and our friend and when
I heard it I said oh this is just sort
of a
she didn't mean that
did you see the people in South Korea
what they were doing as they're standing
there listening that would be one of the
only times where they should have sent
somebody up to talk to her and say
listen you really made a big one we got
to change this you know normally if you
blow it I don't want to have somebody
walk up here say Sir could you re say or
just rephrase it please I'd get angry
but you know what and that one I would
be very happy to receive their advice
because that's one of the worst I've
ever seen that's one of the worst I've
ever seen I think it's just gross it's
gross incompetence in my opinion all of
these local prosecutors officers are
being told what to do by a very corrupt
federal government
where's out there where's out there by
the way at the same time the company
hot as a person but this is a finance
company it's a spec
is being targeted by the SEC now you
know look if they don't come up with a
financing I'll have it private truth
social is hot
it's easier to have it private you have
to go through all this stuff by
miraculous coincidence but you have to
hear this the head of the SEC was the
Chief Financial Officer of crooked
Hillary Clinton's campaign
I said who is he he doesn't seem to be
very reasonable it's not even after me
they're after these poor guys they said
would love to financiers back that's the
end of that they would serve the
subpoena
because they're trying to silence us
but the head think of it the head of the
SEC was the Chief Financial Officer of
crooked Hillary's campaign that she lost
to us
and you won't believe this one but
Melissa hodgment
I call her Melissa Hodgman strzok is the
wife of the legendary Peter strzok of
the FBI
and she's the acting director of
enforcement at the SEC so think of this
Peter strzok's wife
is going after the people wanting to
finance our platform can you imagine is
this again this could only happen to
Trump this doesn't happen to people
remember strzok and his lover Lisa Page
had a torrid Affair and we're writing
love notes about the insurance policy to
take out Trump if
he should win the election should he win
we have an insurance policy you know
what the insurance policy was all of the
things that we've been through over the
last five years
these are dangerous people who are
willing to burn every American
institution to the ground to Target
their political opponents these are very
sick and dangerous people but we will
never let them silence us truth so shall
go out and sign up now it's our voice
the radical left lunatics are doing
everything possible essential to cancel
first this is America First what's wrong
with America first we put our nation
ahead of others that we want to help
others
but we have our nation to watch and our
nation has probably never been in more
dangerous conditions than it is now
everything's going bad everything but
truth is carrying the banner and
carrying it proudly and carrying it well
and we will you guys know truth social
is soon going under right we've covered
it extensively on the channel I'd like
this
[Applause]
they are trying to damage me in order
that I don't run for president so
they're doing if they had thrown them
all the local DA's the state attorney
generals
I had a perfect phone call in Atlanta
Georgia like so perfect the one where he
asked for 11
780 votes so remember that that was a
perfect call to
fact the fair people said wow that was a
good call I heard people say I never
knew you were so nice I never knew you
were so nice a lot of senators told me
that I never knew you could be so nice
these are disinformation maniacs
and the I need 11 000 votes give me a
break it's ever one you want to use
they're close enough to each other
they all say they they really want to
run against President Trump only the
viewers of this channel would be dumb
enough to buy this coin that's what they
do we want to run against Trump by the
way let's put them under investigation
in 19 different locations
no but I did I had a friend said to you
you must be the most honest human being
and because it would take days to find
somebody that's been going on for years
this is going on now for six years six
years six years ever since I came down
that beautiful golden escalator and
Trump Tower
the radical left things
that's the Mexican rapist speech
venomous things they're making us weaker
but actually they're making us much
stronger and much more Unified
in all seriousness if someone bought
that stupid coin what do you do with it
you think the people dumb enough to buy
it would like display it on their mantle
do they even have a mantle do they know
what a mantle is failed remember that I
used to get a subpoena I have a
wonderful son named Eric Trump I don't
believe there's anybody in the history
of our country this is a wonderful kid
this is a wonderful guy doing a great
job isn't he like 40 something subpoena
subpoena
he said I think I have the world record
dead
but they uh went after us for years and
you know it's amazing people come up to
me a very strong guy a few days ago came
up to me super strong uh a tough guy
very tough very successful many of you
would know his name but I won't give his
name because I don't know if he likes it
he's probably afraid to give his name
but he came up to me could I ask you a
question Mr President what how do you
take it she said take what the abuse
that you're given by these people with
all of the investigations I couldn't
last for two days I said do I have a
choice I don't have a choice I don't
have a choice but he's tough but a lot
of people ask me that they ask me that
question how do you do it and we still
were one of the most successful
presidents and administrations in the
history of our conference right
right Boris
right
interview any of these people for five
full minutes about what they see as
Trump's accomplishments and you'll see
how soft this support is
for example I took a dilapidated broken
and tired landmark building in
Washington DC called The Old Post Office
it was shot
it had be been empty for I don't know
different numbers like 30 years 50 years
many many years that sat there it is
before and after but we took that
building we invested a tremendous amount
of money and energy into it and energy
is just as so he made real estate deals
as president huh we spent a lot of time
and a lot of effort and did a fantastic
job my family myself and we made it into
an absolute work of art it's so
beautiful
yeah
all right
and it opened and it became very very
successful in fact I upped the budget
during the course because I just like
with the wall
I built the wall and then I said let's
build more we build more he could have
finished the rest of it in three weeks
just same thing I said let's go with all
the best marble in the lobby let's go
with the best fixtures but we just upped
it and it is it was great please put the
best pictures in the building that's the
best get
how did he get it I think there was
another subpoena
how did I get it anybody else gets it
you know
but how did I get it then I sold it and
we made a profit and then they wanted to
start another investigation and then
they found out that I got it from the
Obama Administration long before
[Music]
that was the end wow
that was the end of that I got it from
Obama and by the way the head of the GSA
who was very professional the people in
the GSA are fantastic by the way but the
head of the GSA I believe was fired
shortly after that when he heard I got
it he went crazy the best people fired
up because he didn't like me much even
before the fact
but I built a great company with very
very low debt and a tremendous amount of
cash and this is a crowd that really is
excited by real estate conglomerates
with low debt ask me and demean me
and also to demean the people in this
and by this crowd I mean like anyone who
has to work for a living all that good
at demeaning people leading people
astray because our movement's historics
Frank the radical left Democrats have
set the power of law enforcement against
me at a level never seen before in the
history of our country you have no idea
I mean people
coming out we have an MS DNC you know
what the msdnc is yeah
yeah it's called MSNBC but we call it Ms
DNC that's Democrat National Committee
right Ms Democrat National Committee who
another one got elected on I'll take
Trump down I'll take Trump and she's
heading up at DA's office someplace
uh it is so horrible what they've done
and you know they never get down to like
how do we make our country great it's
always like let's investigate everybody
let's do and they're the ones that
should be investigated because they're
the Crooked people it's sort of what
those people do as their job they
investigate possible crimes
time to stand
[Applause]
[Music]
active left-wing tyrants then you need
to stand with the mega make America
great again
and we had it great we had it great
we had it
and remember prior to the China virus
coming into our country
they like to call it covet I like to
call it more accurately the China virus
but prior to the China virus coming in
we did numbers in the history of the
world nobody's ever done the numbers we
were doing and then when that plague
came in we had to rebuild it again and
we did it a second time and we handed
them back a stock market that was higher
than it was just prior
to the China virus coming in and much
higher than it is right now okay has
anybody have a 401k is anybody happy
with their 401k
people are down remember guys on average
since the start of the stock market
stocks do better under democratic
presidents than Republican presidents
does it always happen no does it usually
happen yes let's wait until the end of
Joe Biden's presidency and you need to
[Applause]
if you don't want America to become a
third world country and we are heading
toward becoming a third world country if
you look at the election offices if you
look at the way they counted the ballots
remember
the ballot counter is far more important
sadly in our country oh God than the
candidate that's why you people have to
be very careful
tutor you better be careful one thing
with Matt Matt gets it we're not going
to have any problems anymore because he
will straighten it out he's tough as
hell
these centers
but the vote counter is in our country
in my opinion far more important than
the candidate we just saw that
then you need to ensure these Thugs and
zealots go down in the largest midterm
defeat our nation has ever seen because
one thing the more votes you get the
harder it is for them to cheat but they
figure it out anyway no matter what the
left-wing tyrants throw at us no matter
what they do to us we have no choice we
have to keep on going we have to keep on
fighting because we are on a mission to
restore the Republic to Greatness by the
way I have to admit I only just noticed
that now they've got protect girls
sports signs for the people that are
strategically placed uh on on stage so
he's definitely doing the teach
transgender line tonight
by the way is there anything better than
a trump rally on a delay Saturday
afternoon slash evening
having a good time talking about bad
things we're talking about bad things
but we're having as good a time as you
can have considering the subject but
we'll be talking about great things
someday and hopefully not too distant
future you could take the five worst
Presidents in American history and I
would outdo all of them as how bad I am
done the damage Joe Biden has done to
our nation in less than two years
we could end up in a third world war
remember
you want to know and I said it the other
day on the great Sean Hannity show we
love Sean but I said I would rather see
as somebody that loves our country I
would rather see Joe Biden do a great
job for this country even if it meant
that we may not be successful you know
what this is all about right Trump is so
scared of the prosecutions that may rain
down upon him that he's actually sort of
starting to do this plausible soft
Praise of Biden it's it's really
something two years ago when I was in
office gasoline
was it 1.87 cents a gallon it actually
had a period where it's at a dollar
fifty
it actually hit one dollar and fifty
cents at one point now gas is
five dollars six dollars seven dollars
and even the other day despite the fact
that they're stealing from the national
strategic Reserves
the other day in California you had an
area where it was eight dollars a gallon
all right so uh obviously you guys
probably understand that this is a lie
uh when Donald Trump left office gas was
uh like 230
um and it's now 370 and just about
everything he says is a lie or a
distortion but I know I don't need to
tell most of you that
and they brag because it came down just
a little bit they said well gasoline go
so dollar 87 even a dollar fifty during
the term a little bit and they say well
drop 20 cents it dropped 20 cents yeah
it's like four dollars and eighty cents
under my leadership
does he not think this information's
public we're heading toward energy
dominance total dominance
we were going to be bigger than Saudi
Arabia sorry
we were going to be bigger than Saudi
Arabia and Russia combined and you could
add Venezuela where we're now we're
going begging for oil in Venezuela can
you imagine we're like Beggars we're
like begging for we're actually
producing more oil now than when Trump
was President I'm not saying it's good
or bad it just is
the old-fired power station every single
week think of this
fired power stations plants
always next to a brand new solar panel
plant that makes these panels to sell to
the United States a tremendous prices
think of it so we're putting these
plants hey can you imagine during the
flood if we had nice big solar Fields
all over the place how long would they
last not too long would they no but they
built they're building coal-fired plants
all over China and they're building
solar plants so that the suckers can buy
the solar plants and I'm not against
solar wind is a disaster by the way
they're ruining our Fields they're
ruining everything they're killing our
Birds I don't know the environmentalists
they like wind they're destroying your
Fields they're destroying everything
killing all the birds and then they say
we're like when it's also the most
expensive energy you can get
yeah we've covered this extensively uh
fossil fuels kill way more animals than
the windmills kill birds also by
painting just one of the blades of the
windmills you reduce the number of birds
who hit them by something like 95
percent it's really absurd in American
history you know that all the stuff that
you're seeing now where they're taking
trillions of dollars for the green new
deal it's like throwing it right out the
window you might as well throw it out
the window waste of time and you know
what it's going to cause more inflation
than you've ever seen I used to say
we're going to end up being Venezuela on
steroids and I never thought it would
happen first of all I thought we were
going to easily win the election which
we did but I never thought it was going
to happen but I used to say
we are going to end up being Venezuela
and steroids that's exactly where we're
heading right people don't realize you
know Venezuela 20 years ago was very
very successful and then they started
doing exactly what our country is doing
and look at them now they don't have
water they don't have food
everyone's fleeing they're fleeing the
one thing we're really missing to make
us like Venezuela is actual socialists
or Communists in power inflation we had
no inflation
Biden and the democrat congress created
the worst inflation in 51 years
9.2 percent now I have to say that the
inflation is going to get much higher
now it's probably much higher right
after the election what probably happens
I rebuilt our military including our
nuclear capability and the creation of
space force which was so badly needed
but they surrendered our strength and
turned Afghanistan into the greatest
humiliation our country has ever seen I
believe that was the most humiliating
point in time in the history of our
country and now we have a war between
Russia and Ukraine with potentially
hundreds of thousands of people dying
that would never have happened that war
would never ever have happened if I were
president and it didn't happen for four
years plus a long campaign it didn't
happen would have never happened with
Putin never never ever
two years ago so for people wondering
we're only about 51 minutes in
um this may be a sort of Fidel Castro
like two and a half hour speech because
it started sort of on time and it's
indoors so Trump's probably comfortable
as far as the temperature goes we could
be here for at least another 90 minutes
and Visa
visas Thirteen the worst gang members
they carve people up with knives because
it's much more painful than a bullet and
it takes a lot longer they killed two
young girls walking to High School in
Long Island they killed them and they
sliced them up because they wanted to
see pain and this is the people and by
the way many of the people coming in
they're from the prisons of a hundred
other countries in this world not just
the three or four with Mexico and
Guatemala and El Salvador
you know we think these are coming in
from prisons all over the world they're
dumping we're like a Dumping Ground the
United States has become a Dumping
Ground for the prisoners of other
countries because they don't want to
spend the money to take care of these
people for the next 50 years how stupid
are we and we built hundreds of miles of
border wall we did a great job and
that's really the reason despite
remember I got sued for two and a half
years two and a half years by democrats
as soon as 11 different lawsuits I won
every single one of them and we built it
completely finished the original plan
and then never happened much more wall
and we almost got that finish too they
would have done it in three weeks
in short the election was rigged and
sold our country is being absolutely
destroyed because of it I ran twice I
won twice I did much better the second
time than I did the first getting
millions and millions of more votes in
24 20. than we did in 2016 and likewise
getting more votes than any sitting
president in the history of our country
as I said
and now we might it's honestly starting
to seem like even his crowds don't
really believe that crap
oh I think you're going to be happy
you know under these ridiculous rules
and regulations you're not allowed to
talk about it the campaign Finance laws
we have in this country are so stupid
all these pesky rules are regulations
but first we have to
[Music]
have to job number one for a republican
Congress is to stop the invasion of our
Southern border it's an invasion we're
being invaded no different than an army
of soldiers pouring across
these are an army of many many criminals
following across and we have no idea who
they are where they come from we know
nothing about them in Arizona last month
great state and a legal alien criminal
was sentenced for walking into a
convenience store taking out his gun
executing the wonderful young 21 year
old clerk in Cold Blood on camera and
walking out with a pack of cigarettes
from behind the couch he did it for a
pack of cigarettes
his parents are devastated as they would
be he did it for a pack of cigarettes an
animal and then they say you shouldn't
call a person an animal he's an animal
last week in New York an illegal alien
was sentenced to
a very short sentence for stabbing a
police officer in the neck out of
nowhere grabbing his gun and firing at
other officers
think of that that's that's I call her
peekaboo that's peekaboo the think of
that that's your
State Attorney General making it almost
impossible with her rules and
regulations to ever put a real criminal
a killer a murderer a drug dealer in
jail
she's the worst
the State Attorney General of New York
peekaboo I think she's the absolute
worst and in Boston last year at a legal
alien Visa overstayer tried to rob a
father of 12 children before mercilessly
stabbing him eight times to his death
the radical Democrats want to turn
America into one giant Saint this is the
lurid crime stories part of the speech
it's part of just about every one of
these speeches
we believe our country should be a
sanctuary for law the really funny thing
about these anecdotes is sometimes when
Trump goes such and such Savage was
sentenced
sentenced sometimes for crimes that were
committed while Trump was president but
he won't ever mention that Patrol agent
Brian Terry
was killed in
the two the Obama administration's Fast
and Furious scheme a scheme so dumb it's
not to be believed we won't even discuss
it the last murderer involved in that
shootout was finally sentenced for his
crimes in a long time
can't we grieve for your loss and we
always will stand with you as we did
during four years of what we were doing
for the hunt and we stand with the
heroes of ice and they are heroes and
the heroes of Border Patrol
they are great great people thank you
where is Kent
as you can have Kent come up
[Applause]
border patrol ice these are great
talented tough people I know a lot of
the people in these rows here they've
been waiting online for three four days
to get in they've got to be really good
first row Jones right first Roger but
you know what uh how depraved do you
have to be to wait for days for a ticket
to a trump rally into a pack of MS-13
gang members and say let's fight it out
and that's what these guys do they fight
it out they're tough as hell they love
our country
and we're going to take good care of
them and we're going to take care of our
border patrol because what they're going
through is ridiculous what are they
going all they had to do is nothing all
they had to do was nothing if they did
nothing we had it stopped and we had
drugs at the lowest point in 57 years
coming into our country the lowest point
because of the wall that we built and
all the other things there's this funny
thing when they stop catching people
with drugs they assume there's less
drugs coming in but it might just mean
you're doing a worse job of catching
them and then they'll go Biden's doing a
terrible job look at all these drugs
that we caught at the border
well but we're catching the drugs right
so they're it's it's very backwards ago
a sadistic
but on a random shooting page
year old mother Slaughter of five mother
of five wonderful young person
at a bus stop
killing another middle-aged woman
murdering a 28 year old man and Gravely
wounding an 80 year old gentleman who
was out walking his dog
much of the crime wave is caused by drug
dealers who during their lives will kill
an average of 500. Will trump call for
the execution of drug dealers but then I
tell the story I'll tell her quickly but
when I was dealing with China
and when I was dealing with Russia
and now he's dealing with all these
countries I got to know him all well and
I asked president she they have 1.5
billion people
and they'd say is he smart I'd say yes
he's smart then the Press would say he's
saying president she is what he has the
ruler of 1.5 billion he's smart China
beyond smart I said president do you
have a drug problem no no no he said
almost I can't even believing the
question no no we have no drug problem
I said that's strange 1.5 billion people
have no drug the only problem they have
is they make the drugs and send them
into our country but we are that close
to stop now it's coming in at levels
fentanyl coming in at levels like we've
never seen before
killing I believe 250 000 people a year
that's a war
but I said you have a drug problem he
said no I said how come quick trial
I said president uh may I ask you what
the hell is a quick trial what is a
quick trial
he said we catch the drug dealer we
bring him to a quick trial
because there's no games you know you
this guy is a fierce guy yeah some of
these people they're fierce they're at
the top of their game here's Trump
praising dictators and authoritarians
she is at the top of his game he
probably says what the hell is going on
with this country called the United
States what is going on
but he said no we catch them and we try
them
it is a quick trial and if convicted I
think probably we can say that close to
100 are convicted
there's another sign of a democracy
close to 100 conviction nobody wants to
be a drug dealer in China and if we did
that in our country
does every crunch every country that
does it
has no drug problem they don't have drug
problems and Singapore and others and it
sounds horrible using that term the
death penalty but you know what for the
police officers where you kill a police
officer it's not fair they shoot them in
their car when they're sitting waiting
watching and they shoot them in the back
of their head while they're sitting in a
car now for police officers and also for
human traffickers they traffic in women
and they kill a lot of them but you have
to have the death penalty and if you
don't do that you're going to have crime
is going to go through the roof
and if you do it and if you have a
meaningful death penalty meaningful and
fair and all of that but if you have a
meaningful death penalty for drug
dealers and traffickers but if you have
a meaningful death penalty crime in our
country will go down 80 to 85 percent in
one day one day it'll take one day there
you go and just remember you know people
don't like hearing it and then they hear
the stats so they say that the one deal
that kills 500 people during his or her
lifetimes that's a lot and they also
destroy families and people so badly so
I really believe that has to be a part
of our platform that has to be a part of
what we do and I think I can say that
from John's standpoint from everybody's
standpoint we have no choice but to do
it it's not like we it's not like we
have a choice we don't have a choice
under a republican Congress we should
also pass emergency funding to hire
thousands and thousands more police
officers Nationwide
to put violent criminals Behind Bars and
keep them
Behind Bars and the other thing is leave
our police alone let them do their job
give them back their respect they know
what to do we have to allow them to do
it
wow they want to take away all sorts of
protections for our police officers and
they still want to Define I'll tell you
what these radical lefts they want to
defund our police
ever heard
and if you warm
today I'd live a little warm this
building was not meant for this many
people right and I want to thank the
officials for allowing a lot and many
thousands of people still couldn't get
in but this was uh especially you know
you had your team playing today so all
right how did they do they won I think
right did they won your team played
sports ball
go Blue
good team did they win okay that's what
I thought the first step to restoring
Public Safety is defeating the radical
Democrats this November and that starts
with trouncing Whitmer don't forget
the only one that benefited was her
husband
her husband was a big benefit this year
Gretchen Whitmer is one of the most
radical most Sinister governors in
America you know that she cruelly
imposed the most brutal lockdowns in the
entire country causing Michigan to lose
more jobs than any other state in the
Union I bet you didn't know that
Gretchen whitmer's horrific school
closures inflicted severe and
irreversible harm on countless Michigan
children and Michigan parents will never
ever forgive her for that meanwhile her
Administration is relentlessly pushed
critical race Theory blatant racism and
transgender Insanity
upon our children Whitmer is also an
anti-energy extremist by the way just as
Trump tells these various lies just so
people know a little bit of the context
right now Whitmer is winning by an
average of 10. now this doesn't mean
anything other than who's ahead right
does it teams can be ahead and lose a
sports game I know many of you have seen
it right now Whitmer is up 10 and
Trump's acting like it's a foregone
conclusion that Tudor Dixon is going to
be the next Governor it's not looking
that way fortunately
Auto industry forever meanwhile Gretchen
Whitmer is presiding over the worst
crime wave in the history of your state
yet she supports deadly Sanctuary cities
abolishing us drivers license for
illegal aliens and she said she supports
the spirit I support she said the spirit
of defunding the police that's bad
thank you
to top it all off Gretchen Whitmer is a
radical abortionist who is and you see
this that was a brain glitch right there
I don't know how many of you saw that
that was a brain glitch late term
abortion through the ninth month of
pregnancy
and even after the baby is born that's a
lie and there are essentially no
abortions at nine months talk to OB gyns
ask them about it they can tell you all
about it after the baby is born these
are radical these are radical
these are radical abortionists Ronald
Reagan and myself like Ronald Reagan
believe in the exceptions for rape and
incest and the life of the mother I
believe in the exceptions but the
radical Democrats believe in abortion
and really right from the moment of
birth and even after birth you can't let
this happen there's no country in the
world that wants what these crazy people
want next will be Hillary wants to kill
four-year-olds from the wombs remember
during the debate with crooked Hillary
Clinton I said they want to rip the baby
oh here we go home even though then the
ninth month Michigan you need to dump
this wild eye extremist Gretchen Whitmer
and put Tudor Dixon in the governor's
match not gonna happen dude
good woman
we have to keep our country gay people
but it's not I mean
Tudor is a mother with a beautiful
family a patriot and a former small
business owner I knew her father her
father was so proud of her passed away
recently but a wonderful steel person I
learned a lot about steel from him he
knew it better than anybody
but she's had a decade of experience in
the steel manufacturing business with a
family was very successful
and had I not put the tariffs on the
seal companies for coming in from China
and China Steel we really hit them hard
we took in American companies pay the
tariffs sadly
washing machine in the
Industries we took in
dollars in tariffs and taxes from China
they did not like me too much
that's why a lot of people said I wonder
why covet came here
she will fight for Michigan families
like no one has ever fought before I've
been with her for now a long time she's
a great person we introduced her at
my last rally up here and she took off
like a rocket ship tutor is a national
leader in the battle she's down 10. to
our children by getting race and gender
ideology out of the classroom and return
our schools to teaching Reading Writing
and arithmetic right the old-fashioned
Reading Writing and arithmetic
Junior will stop the Whitmer crime wave
and that's what it is it's a crime wave
in your state and she has pledged to
deliver one billion dollars to
strengthen police forces across your
state is he going to call my tutor is
endorsed by nearly two dozen County
Sheriffs and almost all of the police
she will defend your job she will defend
your manufacturing she will defend your
safety and she will defend your values
so I'd like to just ask tutor please see
this is a good Super Chat right here
this is exactly what we all need to be
saying these people are nuts check out
how crazy this lady is now just remember
when Trump calls up a candidate they
mostly have to praise Trump otherwise
Trump gets visibly bored
Harvest Bread
[Applause]
thank you so much so I just want to say
that when we took a little break I spoke
before I went out and talked to the
media and I had one of the folks from
the media ask me an interesting question
she said I listened to your acceptance
speech and I listened to your speech
tonight and I think you hit Whitmer
pretty hard do you think that you're
coming off as a mean girl
so funny the truth hurts
we're not going to let our kids
be radicalized we're not going to let
our kids be sexualized we're not going
to let our law enforcement be demonized
we're not going to tell our businesses
they can't expand and everything I've
said about Gretchen whitmer's record is
true
no that's a lot
this has like this statement is false
sort of vibes
so all I
like trying to make re-election happen
Gretchen
I look forward to your concession speech
tutor
thank you thank you tutor
we're also joined by
Tudor's excellent choice for lieutenant
governor great guy Shane Hernandez Shane
okay Shane good great job you're doing
great good choice
Shane's an outstanding leader and a rock
solid conservative and he's doing
fantastically well so popular in the
state and you're going to really help to
bring it back because it's really going
down quite badly so thank you very much
they're gonna lose
this November you also need to get out
and vote for two other brilliant and
courageous Warriors running Statewide
this guy is so tough I don't know I'm
gonna scare you you're gonna say he's
too tough you need toughness and uh it's
what they've done to this state
everyone respects her because he's one
of the most successful lawyers in your
state he gave up so much to do this and
he will be better than anybody you've
ever had your next Attorney General Matt
deperno and your next secretary of state
Christina caramo please come up
these two are really nutty I mean I'm
talking about nuttier than you know
squirrel droppings
[Applause]
thank you
hello
so president Trump is right there are
other people like myself out there being
investigated by the radical left
and here's the thing the media does
want to report the truth they hide it
from you this is what is going on people
the Democrats in this country are using
their offices taxpayer funds to go out
and weaponize their offices and attack
Republicans Tim Ryan said it just the
other week if we can't cancel notice
that Trump's board because the guys not
mostly praising Trump Trump's already
bored you have to praise Trump when he
brings you up to speed to speak he's
almost looking irritated by you people
it is terrifying what they're doing and
my opponent Dana nessel is a coward
coward
to the drug lords bringing illegal
fentanyl across our border she's a
coward because she hides in her basement
and refuses to debate me
and I say this people the media every
one of them every one of you fake news
media people it's only right-wing media
at these rallies
you should be demanding that your
elected officials come out of the
Shadows get on stage and support their
positions and debate
now I gotta say one other thing people
it better be about recently
Roe versus Wade was overturned
and that would not have happened
without the man standing next to me
right
there it is
who had the courage to appoint and stand
with three conservative justices and put
them on the Supreme Court
now one last thing you nominated me to
be attorney general right I will fight
for you I will fight against the radical
left I will fight for parental rights in
this state
okay I will fight for election integrity
and I will bring Crime down across the
state and make your community safe again
this guy will almost certainly be
defeated in a humiliating loss I I want
you to give an Applause for Donald Trump
who helped overturn Roe verse Wade
she doesn't look like she wants to speak
we're kind of forcing her
so right now the Biden Administration is
suing the state of Arizona to prevent
them from checking citizenship status
before registering people to vote that's
a big issue in Michigan as you can
imagine
why would they want to do that and if
you point out the obviously because they
want to dump a bunch of illegal
registration since the voter
registration database they'll call you a
conspiracy theorist and then my opponent
likes to claim that she's against voter
ID okay Michigan she claimed that she's
against voter ID because a lot of people
have a hard time getting it doesn't land
out a question for you whose job is it
to make sure people have an ID
it's the job of the Secretary of State
to ensure people have an ID so if
there's lots of people across the state
without an ID it sound like she's
failing at her job and it needs to be
removed from office
kind of obvious
sadly you will also lose and be
humiliated
[Applause]
aging war on our sovereignty their
Waging War on our freedom that's why
they're pushing proposition 2 to allow
private money in our elections do you
know my opponent was one of the
Architects behind zuckbooks where they
pumped Millions upon millions of dollars
in the Battleground state to find these
illegal battle meal operations and on
camera you have multiple individuals
she's scary crazy dipurno is just like
calculated crazy
she's truly bonkers
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll demonize you for simply wanting a
fair and honest election as I've said
again this is the biggest threat to our
freedom our elections are the heartbeat
of our freedom and they're trying to put
our knife in the heart of our Liberty by
intentionally and consistently
corrupting our election system and
demonizing citizens who want to speak
truth about it that's why I'm determined
to be your next secretary of state and
we need to make sure
right
we need to make sure that we defeat
proposition two and as my buddy Matt
here pointed out what Tim Ryan said
about killing the map she's scary crazy
and she's going on way too long for
Trump's attention span a movement which
will unite America
demographics and take back our country
demand our freedom protect our children
and we will stop these people and there
is nothing they can do to stop this Mega
movement and guess what
foreign
we will have a sweeping and decisive
victory in November and take those three
Psychopaths out of Lansing thank you
it's it's genuinely not looking good for
any of these candidates in uh Michigan
if you look at the polling
Fortune
foreign
thank you
thank you very much get out and vote
that's what you need finally right here
in Michigan's 10th congressional
district you have the privilege of
voting for a incredible Patriot a West
Point graduate a U.S army veteran a
successful businessman and your next
congressman John James
thank you John
thank you good man
we're also joined tonight by
Representatives Tim Wahlberg is a
warrior Lisa McLean a warrior and of
course Marjorie Taylor green
[Applause]
and your next congressman from
Michigan's 8th District Paul Young
good luck Cole
I hear you're doing very well Paul
state representatives Matt Maddock and
Stephen Cara
thank you fellas great thank you thank
you thank you very much
State Senate candidate who's doing very
well I understand Jonathan Lindsey
good Jonathan thank you very much
State House candidates Angela rigas
Rachelle Smith and Mike hoadley thank
you
thank you very much good luck
they're all doing well I think
Republicans are going to be doing very
well a friend of mine a great General a
great person that I've known for a long
time one of the earliest of all the
generals and one of the best of all the
generals Keith Kellogg Keith there you
go
thank you
[Applause]
thank you
and Mike thank you for being here again
thank you very much I'm still thinking
about ordering that Trump coin everyone
here today over four incredible years we
achieved more for the workers and
families of Michigan than any
Administration
in the history of our country after
Decades of false promises and bitter
betrayals from other politicians I
stopped the plunder of Michigan jobs I
ended NAFTA the worst trade deal ever
made
he replaced it with usmca which is
essentially identical probably ever made
we had a great time and now Canada and
Mexico want to renegotiate I tell them
by the administration don't do it
they had their way for many many decades
and now we have our way we have a great
trade deal keep it don't renegotiate it
don't let them do that I withdrew from
the job-killing trans-pacific
partnership would have killed everything
here including your car business and
renegotiated Obama's terrible Korea deal
the worst deal you could imagine saving
Michigan's Auto industry from certain
ruin and death
to protect American workers I place
stiff tariffs on foreign aluminum
foreign steel and many other products
thank you very much they were thrilled
China was thrilled
and other countries too they paid a lot
of money we took in 420 million dollars
nobody else took in 10 cents from China
in all these years not one president
think of it not one president took in 10
cents we took in 420 billion at least we
live by remember that the tariffs are
paid by American companies hi here
America
I stood up to China we stood up to all
of these countries
all of these countries we stood up to
them no other president's ever done that
they didn't want to do that we then gave
28 billion dollars to our Farmers
because of is it possible that the gold
coin is actually Hanukkah gelt probably
not right there's to negotiate a better
deal with me and I met the farmers and I
said I they were well represented but
all they wanted was a Level Playing
Field they didn't want anything else and
I said what do you think they said you
have to negotiate a great deal we'll
suffer through it but I know you'll do a
great job but without them we couldn't
have done what we did and we did we
suffered through it for a year and China
caved and gave us everything and we
ended up with 28 billion dollars that I
handed back to the farmers in the form
of lots of beautiful checks and it all
came right out of the wallet of China
and that was just a small part of the
money we took in from China very small
part I also authorized millions of
dollars to rebuild Michigan Soo locks we
know that you know that was just dying
what and it's all being rebuilt and
built and got you hundreds of Millions
for the Great Lakes restoration
initiative I got you all of that money
without me you wouldn't have had that
money they didn't want to give it to you
the Democrats we fought for Michigan we
won from Michigan and this November we
are going to fight and win for Michigan
once again
none of those races are looking very
good
one of the first
yes so there's people talking about this
woman's shirt this woman on our left her
shirt says Jesus Is My Savior and then
below it says Trump something does
anybody know what the Trump part is
Jesus Is My Savior but Trump trump is
what I might say it I said we're going
to give you parents rights
where the hell has our country been
at long last every parent in America
must be empowered to opt out of the
indoctrination and send their child to
the public private Charter religious and
home school of their choice
and we will keep men out of women's
sports you know those stories oh boy
here we go
you know those stories records are being
broken on a daily basis records that
have stood for many years of being
broken on a daily basis very unfair and
no teacher should ever be allowed to
teach transgender to our children
without it there it is Parental concept
right there it is
the welfare of America's women and
children
now you know people really love Melania
our first lady
first lady I'm realizing This Woman's
dressed crazier than this one we got all
these signs we love our first lady
he is continuing to help children
through her be best initiative fostering
the future it is standing up for young
people an initiative that started as a
grammar error that they have to double
down on and our support she's done a
great job
done a great job
thank you Melania
the Republican party will continue to be
the party of the American Family the
American child and the party of the
American dream which is rapidly going
away
we'll bring it back
the radical left Democrat Party is not a
50 party within our country
there against God Guns oil law
enforcement voter ID tax cuts regulation
cuts are against all of these things
they're against the Constitution
and the founding fathers other than that
they're great aren't they oh god now
think of it they're against all of those
things
the way they win is today they're
against oxygen cheat like dogs
everywhere the Republican party has the
chance he treated him like a dog he
reforms Matt
you and Christina will do a job
including Universal voter ID citizenship
confirmation they don't want
confirmation that somebody's not a
citizen are you a citizen it's none of
your business oh they have right this is
crazy
they are against citizenship think of
that voter ID citizenship confirmation
no more fake drop boxes no private money
pouring into local election offices
you got to get your approval from state
legislatures which they didn't do and
ultimately we need same-day voting with
only paper ballots Trump voted by mail
weeks early
folks that's what 1.5 million people
looks like at a rally few months ago
they had only paper ballots they had
same-day voting 36 million people voted
nobody complained at the end
they have a winner they have a loser
nobody complained and if they have a
complaint they can check the paper it
doesn't just disappear you know
disappears Into Thin Air
by the way
Lisa please stand up Lisa Acclaim uh-oh
congresswoman doing a great job oh I
didn't know
I didn't know you were here it's pillow
great Lisa doing a great job thank you
she doing good Marjorie good yes
Marjorie says yes that's okay with me
we're just six weeks away from the most
important midterm election in American
history and we need a landslide so big
that the radical left cannot rig it or
steal it we have a landslide right right
tuner right
early voting you started to
go so get out and vote vote for Tudor
Shane Matt Christina and John and all
the others without delay vote Republican
will bring back your country this is the
year we're going to take back the house
we're going to take back the Senate
we're going to take back America and in
2024 most importantly we are going to
take back our beautiful beautiful
magnificent White House people are
starting to come whoa Reggie
edgy stuff
together we will fight for more jobs for
Michigan families fair trade for
Michigan workers and more Michigan
factories forging more products stamped
with that beautiful phrase made in the
USA we put it all over the place
nobody's ever done the job we did a
whole bunch of Trump's campaign stuff
was made in China it was back to China
hate to tell you we will shut down
Biden's border disaster reinstitute our
strong remain in Mexico policy how's
that policy
you think that was easy and then they
gave it up on day one remain in Mexico
no let's let them come into our country
unchecked
a terrible just terrible the thought
process is so sick strengthen the
Patriots of ice and Border Patrol
we will again end Catch and Release we
will end chain migration we will end the
Visa Lottery
we will clamp down on illegal
immigration just like we do we think he
will do the sad music with the dystopian
ending today what do people think years
ago we had the safest Border in our
history and nobody even disputes it not
even the fake news back there
we will stop the crime wave and
democrat-run cities where we give our
police the power they need and the
respect that they deserve and we will
not take legal protection away from our
police we will help our police we will
restore Law and Order in America
you're not going to have people shooting
you as you walk down the sidewalk with
your child
we will hold China accountable for
unleashing the virus upon the world
we will defend our constitution we will
defend the Second Amendment which is
under siege and we will proudly uphold
the judeo-christian values and
principles of our nation's founding
we will restore patriotic education to
our schools and we will teach our
children to love their country honor our
history and to always respect our Great
American flag
in conclusion
make America great again is by far the
greatest political in conclusion was a
sign in sixth grade book reports that
you didn't read the book but he says oh
gee it might not be there was a movement
200 years ago
now there's never been anything like
this and by the way far more people than
you think far more this isn't a 50 50
country far far more than you think
together we're standing up against some
of the most menacing forces entrenched
interests and vicious opponents our
people have ever seen before despite
great outside dangers our biggest
threats Remain the sick Sinister and
evil people from within our country from
within you know the people I'm talking
about you see them all the time
lie disinformation cheat steal but no
matter how big or powerful the corrupt
radical left Democrats that we are
fighting against maybe you must never
forget this nation does not belong to
them this nation belongs to you to you
all of you
all right
this is your home this is your heritage
and our American Liberty is your
god-given right remember that
from Marquette
to Midland oh no
from Mackinac to Saginaw
and from Lansing to beautiful Ann Arbor
to right here in Warren
we inherit the legacy of Michigan
Patriots who gave their Blood Sweat and
Tears for this beloved Nation
this is the state where Henry Ford
invented the assembly line Henry Ford
was a disgusting anti-semite look it up
surprised entire Industries and Michigan
is the state that gave us Motown and
Mustang
the unrivaled might of the American
Midwest unrivaled
your Michigan ancestors forged the steel
built the Cities laid out the railroads
worked the factories Henry Ford was a
pro-hitler
anti-semitic propagandist who funded the
printing of an anti-semitic screed
called the protocols of the Elders of
Zion
[Music]
oh no
it's the Q Anon part of the rally
[Applause]
[Music]
but now
we are a nation in Decline
we are a failing Nation
we are a nation that has the highest
inflation in 50 years
and where the stock market finished
the worst first half of the year since
1872
likewise we are a nation that has the
highest energy costs in its history this
is so cringy that I'm like getting the
chills
and we were just hopefully that's not
coveted
[Music]
doing as well as Saudi Arabia Russia and
many others for oil please please please
help us Joe Biden says yet we have more
liquid gold right under our feet
than any other country in the world
we are a nation that is consumed by the
radical lefts green new deal yet
everyone knows this is a degree New Deal
will lead to our destruction we are a
nation whose leaders are demanding all
electric cars even though they can't go
far cost too much and whose batteries
are my electric car can only go 330
miles and as many of you know it's
really common to drive longer than that
without stopping to pee in the the
United States but not available in China
we are a nation that ended oil
exploration and production in the United
States of America
just as the price of oil reached an
all-time high we are a nation that
surrendered in Afghanistan leaving
behind dead soldiers American citizens
and 85 billion dollars worth of the
finest military equipment in the world
we are a nation that allowed Russia to
devastate a country Ukraine
killing hundreds of thousands of people
and it will only get worse it would
never have happened with me as your
commander-in-chief and for four long
years it never did happen and China with
Taiwan
their circling is next
we are a nation that has weaponized its
law enforcement against the opposing
political party like never before
we've got a Federal Bureau of
Investigation that won't allow bad
election-changing facts to be presented
to the public
where Hunter Biden's laptop was Russian
disinformation when they I don't know
guys it's pretty convincing Department
of Justice that refuses to investigate
egregious acts of voting irregularities
and fraud
and we have a president who's
cognitively impaired and in no condition
to lead our country
which may very well end up very soon in
World War III any day we are a nation
that no longer has a free and fair press
fake news is all you get and they are
indeed the enemy of the people
we are a nation where free speech is no
longer allowed where crime is rampant
like never before crowd's ready to go it
has been collapsing where more people
died of covet in 2021 than in 2020
we are a nation that is allowing Iran to
build a massive nuclear weapon and China
to use the trillions of dollars it has
taken from us to build a military to
rival our own
and just two years ago we had Iran China
Russia and North Korea in check they
weren't going to do a thing against us
and everyone knows it they respected
your leader and they respected our
country really crazy and perhaps most
importantly we are a nation that is no
longer respected
we are a nation you cannot find a single
pole that suggests respect for the US
has gone down since Trump left it has
gone up joke and we are a nation that is
hostile to Liberty freedom and faith
we are a nation whose economy is
floundering whose doors are not stocked
whose deliveries are not coming and
whose educational system is ranked at
the very bottom of every single list
we are a nation where large packs of
criminals and thieves are allowed to go
into stores
and openly Rob them beat up the help and
killed people they will kill people and
they kill them they say cool people was
that another glitch even if not
necessary and there is no retribution we
are a nation whose once revered airports
are a dirty crowded mess where you sit
and wait for hours and then are notified
that the plane won't leave and the
peanuts aren't even warm idea
when they will as a nation
are through the roof they don't have the
pilots to fly the plane they don't want
or seek qualified air traffic
controllers
and they don't know
what the hell they're doing
we are a nation that has lost its
confidence its willpower and its
strength we are a nation that has lost
its way
but we are not going to let this
continue two years ago we were a great
nation and we will soon be a great
nation again
[Music]
wow
well I'm inspired hard-working Patriots
like you who built this country and it
is hard-working Patriots like you who
are going to save our country we will
stand up to the radical left Democrats
and the rhinos and we will fight for
America like no one has ever fought
before
there is no mountain we cannot climb oh
God there is no Summit we cannot reach
there is no challenge we cannot meet
there is no Victory we cannot have we
will not Bend we will not break we will
not yield we will never ever ever give
in we will never give up we will never
ever back down
as long as we are confident and United
the tyrants we're fighting do not stand
even a chance
because we are Americans and Americans
kneel to God and God Alone
the silent majority is back and stronger
than ever before my fellow citizens this
incredible journey we are on together
has only just begun
and it is time to start talking about
greatness for our country again
okay
We Are One movement
one people one family and one glorious
American Nation so with the help of
everyone here today and citizens all
across our land vote tutor we will make
America powerful again
[Applause]
we will make America wealthy again
will make America strong again
[Music]
we will make America proud again proud
we will make America safe again
and we will make America great again
thank you Michigan God bless you all
thank you Michigan thank you very much
right
[Music]
yeah anyway more appropriate well
another completely deranged Rally from
Donald Trump
sort of supporting the people he was I
guess allegedly there to support
um but really really really bad and now
he's doing the dancing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well listen we did some great things
today if you are just joining us we did
indeed reach an incredible milestone for
the David Pacman Show YouTube channel
1.5
million subscribers 1.5 million and look
at those numbers climb folks
we are celebrating an incredible number
created the coupon code another half
million which will be good until
midnight next stop 2 million and 100
000 on Twitch and three hundred thousand
on tick tocks and all of it we did some
fact checking we had an okay time I
guess I would say
uh but it all made a lot more sense than
what we saw at the Trump rally that is
for damn sure that is for damn sure I
hope that those of you watching on
Twitch will join our raid going over to
Grand Master Benjamin feingold's Channel
who has been doing some great recent
coverage of various chess controversies
he's a friend of the show is the way I
like to describe Ben Feingold come on
with me we are going to raid very soon
and otherwise Tuesday it is Vance versus
Tim Ryan some of you may know him as JP
Mandel
I know him as JB Vance I don't know that
will be on Tuesday we will have that
debate we will have Mark Kelly versus
Blake Masters on Thursday
so many great events all right see
everybody very soon if you're watching
on Twitch we're heading over to Grand
Master Benjamin Feinberg